For the past 25 years, there has been a tremendous
progress in cancer research.
For example, we know that only 5-10% of all
cancer cases can be attributed to genetic
defects, whereas the remaining 90 - 95% have
their roots in the environment and lifestyle.
We also know that all cancer is the result
of gene mutations.
And these mutations are the fundamental cause
that transform a normal cell into cancerous
cells, that could sustain uncontrolled cell
growth, avoid immune destruction, activating
metastasis, and etc, commonly known as the
10 hallmarks of cancer.
Importantly, there have been tremendous effort
and investment in developing new treatments
targeting these hallmarks with the hope to
kill the tumor cells in our body without much
harm to the normal cells.
As a result, the cancer survival outcome has
improved significantly from 1 in 4 in the
1970s, to today’s survival rate of more
than 50%, and hopefully in the future, we
can increase the survival rate to 3 in 4 by
2034.
Remarkably, treatment for some cancers have
performed much better compared to others,
for example, prostate cancer, breast cancer
and Hodgkin Lymphoma has achieved more than
90% survival rate while other hard to treat
cancers such as brain cancer, glioblastoma,
and pancreatic cancers, the survival rate
remained unchanged in the past 25 years and
management of these diseases remained a challenge
due to lack of treatment option.
Thanks to the advancement of the sequencing
technology, such as the Next generation Sequencing
or NGS technology, the cost of sequencing
of a human genome has reduced from USD 100
million in year 2000 when the first human
genome sequence project was launched, to close
to about USD 1000.
In fact, back in 2019, the Beijing Genomics
Institute offered a service for whole genome
sequencing with the cost of USD 600 per sample.
This is even cheaper than your iPhone!
Today, we have more than 50 petabytes of open
dataset related to cancers, equivalent to
playing mp3 in your iPhone for 100 thousand
years.
The question then became, How to harness the
power of these data for better cure of cancers?
The cancer problem suddenly became a big data
problem.
One way how the big data from cancer research
can be used is to improve the precision of
cancer treatment based on the biology of the
tumor.
For example, back in year 2003, by analyzing
the gene expression of close to about 100
primary tumors from breast cancer patients,
scientists were able to identify 5 major subtype
of breast cancers using unsupervised hierarchical
clustering.
Particularly, 2 of the subtypes that have
demonstrate a clinical significance was the
luminal-like and the basal-like subtype, or
sometime known as the triple negative breast
cancers, where the basal-like subtype breast
cancer has significantly worst prognosis.
Being ER, PR and HER2 negative, the basal-like
tumors do not response to the hormonal therapy
or Herceptin treatment.
The only option at the time was conventional
chemotherapy.
Even that, the response rate was often very
low, in less than 15%.
These findings have grab the attention of
the breast cancer research at that time and
a lot of research was since conducted to target
this refractory subtype of breast cancers.
Today, there are many options for treatments,
including carboplatinum and PARP inhibitors
to target the BRCA-ness of the tumors, and
PD-L1 immune checkpoint inhibitors such as
Atezolizumab.
Of note, this was done 20 years ago before
the explosion of the cancer data and the availability
of the advanced algorithms.
In 2006, a massive effort to catalog the genomics
and biological changes in cancer cells was
launched.
The Cancer Genome Atlas project, or TCGA in
short, is a 10-year project that aims to characterize
the molecular landscape of tumors from more
than 11,000 patients across 33 cancer types,
and defined their many molecular subtypes.
At the completion of the project in 2016,
a total of 2.5 petabytes of data was curated,
across multi-omics platforms, such as genomics,
epigenomics and proteomics, together with
comprehensive clinical data.
The beauty of the project was that, all data
was made accessible by the public under the
open science platform, and anyone or company
are welcomed to use those data to improve
cancer care with no restriction on IP rights
whatsoever.
Using the dataset, the first question we asked
was, are all the cancers similar or how similar
are they from one type of cancer versus another
type of cancer, biologically?
It may sound like a naïve question.
However, if you think about it, most of the
time we define the cancers based on their
anatomical site.
For example, if you have a cancer in the breast,
we called it breast cancer; if you have a
cancer in the lung, we called it lung cancer
and so forth.
The fundamental question is that, if cancer
arise from genetic mutations, will all the
cancers share some kind of similarity, or
will they be different biologically.
The finding was, as anticipated, 90% of the
cancer, do have distinct biology based on
their cell of origin.
This is reassuring as the diagnosis and treatment
that we practice today is highly depend on
the cell or origin classification.
However, what was quite interesting was that,
10% of the tumor shown somewhat shared biology
with different type of cancers.
For example, a subset of bladder cancer are
more similar to lung cancer, while breast
cancer as we know it, can be separated into
luminal-like and basal-like subtype with distinct
biology.
These findings prompt us to think, whether
the drugs that we developed for one type of
cancer, say lung cancer, will be useful to
treat the subtype of bladder cancers that
has high similarity to lung cancer.
If we can do that, it will help the patients
dramatically, as bladder cancer is considered
as a type of rare cancer with limited treatment,
while treatment for lung cancers are widely
available.
With the profiling data, we have also established
a clear picture on the difference between
normal and tumor cells.
Of course, in biology, we understand that
correlation doesn’t mean causation.
The biological differences between tumor and
normal tissue can be the cause of the disease,
or it could be the consequences of the disease.
To understand the causative role of the different
genes in cancer, the project DRIVE, an acronym
for Deep RNAi interrogation of viability effects
in cancer, was launched to identify what genes
are required for the survival of different
type of tumor cells.
By combining the dataset from the TCGA project
which identify genes that are commonly up-regulated
in cancers, and the dataset from the DRIVE
project which identified the cancer driver
genes that is needed for cancer cells to survive,
we can identify targets which can potentially
be useful for future development of targeted
therapy.
Another way how the cancer genomic data can
be used, is to mine the data for drug repurposing
in order to reduce the cost and time of drug
discovery and development.
In average, it is estimated that the Cost
to Develop New Pharmaceutical Drug is bout
$2.5B and take about 10 years from discovery
to clinic.
It takes hundred of thousand of compounds
to be screened in the lab, to get 1 drug that
will eventually be approved by FDA.
That’s if you’re lucky!
This is further complicated with the shortening
of the life-cycle of drugs in the marker due
to rapid appearing of the competitor drug
in the market with better efficacy and profile.
Some were even needed to be withdraw from
the market before the patent ended.
As a result, oncology drug process increase
more than 100-fold in the past 30 years.
Because of these, not only the patients need
to bear the toxic side effects of the drugs,
the family too need to bear the financial
toxicity of cancer treatment.
Indeed, in the recent report published, majority
of Malaysian will only be able to survive
one year when they are diagnose with cancer,
before they go bankrupt and died.
Imagine, each targeted therapy cost about
RM 50k to RM 400k.
How many people can afford it?
However, if we can repurpose some of the drugs
in the market, the cost and the time of development
can be dramatically reduced.
The question is, how can we rapidly and efficiently
discover new indications for existing drugs
with known safety profiles?
Should we go by the traditional high-throughput
screen?
Or can we leverage on the existing data and
AI to identify these drugs candidates?
For example, in pancreatic cancers.
Pancreatic cancer is one of the deadliest
cancers with only 5% survival rate.
Unfortunately, being a deadly and rare cancer,
not many treatment option are available.
The only chemotherapy drug available for pancreatic
cancer is gemcitabine-based regime which has
been used for more than 40 years.
Attempt to combined with targeted therapy
such as EGFR inhibitor, failed to demonstrate
benefit to patients.
We need to rapidly identify drugs that could
treat this refractory cancers.
By using the data derived from large scale
genomic studies, it was shown that pancreatic
cancers are highly heterogenous and can be
stratified into 4 major subtype group based
on their biology.
The so-called squamous subtype of pancreatic
cancer has a significant worse clinical outcome
compare to other subtype of pancreatic cancer.
Based on the gene signature that was identified
from the squamous subtype of pancreatic cancer,
we can compare the differentially expressed
genes in pancreatic cancers with the gene
that are induced by different drugs curated
in the Connectivity Map database, which consists
of gene profile of more than 40,000 drugs,
and more than 1 billion data points.
The idea was to find a drug that could potentially
revert the gene signature of the pancreatic
cancer.
The results show that the SRC inhibitor, EGFR
inhibitors, and potentially IGF1 inhibitors
might be useful to treat the squamous subtype
of pancreatic cancer.
We then prioritize the drug candidate that
are FDA-approved for further testing and showed
that, almost all the SRC inhibitor tested
show synergism with gemcitabine in the squamous-like
pancreatic cancer, as shown in the blue color
contour here, compare to other subtype of
the pancreatic cancer.
Based on these results, a number of clinical
trials are currently ongoing to evaluate the
efficacy of SRC inhibitors for treatment of
pancreatic cancers.
Finally, we can also use open data source
to develop computer vision algorthm, to quicken
the process of screening and reduce mis-diagnosis
of cancer which can be as high as 35%, especially
when it comes to radiology.
The idea was that, if we can combine the wisdom
of experience radiologist in different subfield,
we hope that the AI system trained by these
experts will be able to standardize and improve
the accuracy of detecting cancers earlier.
For example, MIT’s Computer Science and
Artificial Intelligence Lab has developed
a new deep learning-based AI prediction model
that can anticipate the development of breast
cancer up to five years in advance.
The algorithm, which was trained on mammograms
and patient outcomes from over 60,000 patients
from the Massachusetts General Hospital, uses
deep learning to identify patterns that would
not be apparent or even observable by human
clinicians.
Because it’s not based on existing assumptions
or received knowledge about risk factors,
which are at best a suggestive framework,
the results have so far shown to be far more
accurate, especially at predictive, pre-diagnosis
discovery.
Overall, the project is intended to help healthcare
professionals put together the right screening
program for individuals in their care and
eliminate the heartbreaking and all-too common
outcome of late diagnosis.
The technique can also be used to improve
detection of other diseases that have similar
problems with existing risk models which has
far too many gaps and lower degrees of accuracy.
In summary, cancer genomics and big data that
makes use of advanced technologies, such as
DNA sequencing technology and digital pathology,
give scientists enormous power to uncover
how these biological and genomic changes drive
cancer formation and growth.
However, despite the wealth of data being
accumulated about cancer genomics, the actual
benefits are still murky.
For people with a cancer mutation that can
be targeted by an available therapy, there
is no question that cancer-genome sequencing
leads to better outcomes and survival.
But, if overall cancer-survival data are taken
as the endpoint, the benefits might not yet
be as clear.
The number of known cancer-causing mutations
still far outweighs the number of treatments
targeting those mutations.
We need to look at the impact that it has
on those very small subgroups, then we would
consider that the impact of genomics is really
big.